Namo Tassa Bhagavato Harahato Sambha Sambhudassam
Hommage au Bouddha, le Noblesse, le Noblesse et le Seul-Enlightené.
Ce matin, j'aimerais juste expliquer la méthode que nous employons.
Juste pour que ceux de vous qui sont nouveaux à la pratique puissent être clairs.
Pour les personnes qui sont nouvelles, que cela soit clair.
La première chose à comprendre avec Vipassana, c'est que cela n'est pas une psychothérapie.
La purification du cœur arrive naturellement.
La purification du cœur se passe tout seul, de soi.
J'espère que ce soir, je pourrai aller un peu plus en détail par rapport à ça.
C'est aussi important de ne pas pratiquer pour le bien-être physique.
Donc c'est aussi important de ne pas pratiquer seulement pour le bien-être physique.
Bien que les bénéfices physiques sont là, sont reçus.
Nous ne devrions définitivement pas pratiquer pour des bénéfices spirituels.
Parce que si vous vous fixez un but, parce que là vous avez déjà conceptualisé la raison pour laquelle vous allez pratiquer, cela va devenir votre plus grand obstacle.
Parce que tout ce qui se passe durant le processus de vipassana ne se passe pas à cause de nous ou grâce à nous.
Parce qu'il y a en nous cette faculté
qui peut résoudre les choses.
Il n'a pas besoin de nous.
Et en permanence, cela crie, débarrassez-vous de ce méditant de mon chemin.
Donc, notre tâche,
notre tâche est d'établir une attention très pure et permettre à cette intelligence intuitive de se manifester.
Le premier obstacle est la pensée.
Le premier grand obstacle, c'est la pensée.
Les concepts, les idées, les images contiennent nos expériences.
Par exemple, même dans les choses les plus simples, comme le goût d'une épaule,
Par exemple, même dans les choses aussi simples que de goûter une pomme, quand nous goûtons une pomme, immédiatement nous la comparons à toutes les autres pommes que nous avons déjà goûtées, expérimentées.
Parce que toutes les pommes que nous avons goûtées, nous avons dans nos esprits la pomme parfaite.
À cause de toutes les pommes que nous avons goûtées, nous avons dans notre esprit la pomme parfaite.
Notre pomme parfaite.
Celle qui nous plaît.
Ensuite, nous prenons un morceau de pomme et nous déposons sur elle notre idée.
Et cette pauvre pomme doit recevoir notre jugement.
Et beaucoup de pommes deviennent déprimées.
Parce qu'elles ne correspondent pas à notre standard.
Maintenant, cela ne serait pas si mauvais
Ce ne serait pas si grave si nous ne faisions pas aussi cela avec les gens.
Donc, de manière à arrêter cet esprit qui juge, cet esprit qui vient toujours d'une idée conceptuelle,
Et nous le réduisons en un seul mot.
Et ce mot est très concret, il n'est pas abstrait.
Donc lorsque nous expérimentons la respiration,
Nous disons, se lever.
Ceci est un concept mental.
Donc, c'est un concept manufacturé par l'esprit, provoqué par les sensations de la respiration.
De même, quand nous plaçons notre attention au niveau de l'abdomen, nous avons une image, un concept de l'abdomen.
Et donc, avec ces deux manières,
L'esprit nous empêche d'expérimenter la sensation pure provoquée par la respiration.
Mais en gardant l'esprit occupé avec la note mentale, nous pouvons, comme il le dit, déplacer l'attention sur les sensations.
Nous pouvons de cette manière déplacer l'attention sur la sensation.
Pour que finalement la sensation soit plus évidente que ce concept dans notre esprit.
Et quand nous faisons la note mentale, parfois le mot semble très bruyant, fort.
C'est comme si nous ne pouvions rien ressentir.
C'est comme si cela nous empêchait de ressentir les sensations.
Mais ce que cela montre aux méditants est que cette intelligence intuitive est prisonnière dans l'intellect.
Il y a des exemples où, lorsque la pensée est lâchée, la réponse émerge.
donc l'exemple peut-être le plus célèbre est Archimède donc si vous vous souvenez il devait prouver que la couronne du roi était faite d'or et pour faire cela il devait découvrir la gravité le poids spécifique de ce métal
Vous vous souvenez tous comment découvrir le poids, la gravité.
Vous allez pouvoir me corriger.
Vous divisez le volume par le poids ou le poids par le volume.
Il est en train de se battre parce qu'il peut trouver le poids.
Il est en conflit parce qu'il essaie de trouver le poids.
Parce qu'il ne peut pas trouver le volume d'un objet qui n'est pas régulier.
Donc, souvenez-vous, c'est seulement à partir du moment où il se détend, où il coule dans ce bain chaud, que le déplacement de l'eau est égal au volume de son corps, de son propre corps.
Et son exclamation était « J'ai trouvé !
» Eureka !
Donc, notre objectif est d'utiliser l'intellect pour nous aider, mais ensuite de l'abandonner.
Donc, ces mots de note sont
poussant l'attention vers l'objet.
Donc, ces notes mentales sont là pour nous pousser vers l'objet.
Voilà, en direction de l'objet.
Donc la méthode Mahasi l'explique comme si c'était de jeter une pierre contre un mur.
Donc s'il y a une marque dans le mur que vous voulez viser et bien vous regardez à cet endroit et puis vous jetez la pierre en visant cet endroit.
Donc c'est comme si nous conduisions l'attention à l'intérieur de l'objet.
Donc la première chose, je suis très détendu.
Ensuite j'apporte l'attention sur la respiration.
Et j'emploie une note mentale très simple, s'élever, s'abaisser.
Et la note mentale doit être en même temps que le mouvement.
Parce que si vous notez mentalement avant que la respiration se passe, et bien vous auriez l'impression que vous contrôlez la respiration.
Tandis que si vous notez continuellement avec le mouvement, eh bien, vous pouvez vraiment pénétrer la sensation.
Donc, le fait de noter n'est pas seulement pendant l'assise, mais si vous pouvez, juste le faire.
Mais aussi de vous rappeler de le faire tout le temps.
Tandis que vous ouvrez la porte, vous avez la sensation du bras qui bouge pour aller ouvrir la porte.
Donc, en même temps que le bras bouge, vous pouvez utiliser la note bouger.
Ou atteindre.
Parfois, ce qui se passe, c'est que le mot n'arrive pas naturellement à nous chercher un mot.
Parfois nous n'arrivons pas à trouver le mot exact pour décrire ce que nous expérimentons.
Et à ce moment-là nous commençons à penser.
Nous cherchons un dictionnaire.
À ce point, la méthode ne fonctionne pas pour nous.
Si un mot ne vient pas, alors choisissez juste n'importe quel mot.
Si, par exemple, il y a un sentiment dans le corps pour lequel il n'y a pas de mot simple,
Par exemple, s'il y a une sensation dans le corps et qu'il n'y a pas un mot simple pour la décrire, alors décrivez le processus du ressenti.
Si il y a une action pour laquelle une parole ne vient pas immédiatement, notez juste le mouvement.
Si il y a une action pour laquelle un mot ne vient pas immédiatement, alors simplement notez « bouger ».
Donc faites attention de ne pas passer trop de temps pour essayer de trouver le bon mot.
Mais parfois, chercher pour le bon mot peut nous éveiller à quelque chose que nous n'avions pas remarqué initialement.
Et ça, c'est particulièrement le cas pour des attitudes ou des émotions que nous n'avions pas vraiment remarquées.
Remarquez initialement.
Souvent ce sont des émotions ou des états mentaux où nous nous sommes dit je ne devrais pas expérimenter cela.
Des émotions comme par exemple la culpabilité.
La honte.
la jalousie.
La plupart des gens n'aiment pas dire d'eux-mêmes qu'ils sont jaloux.
Pour cette raison, nous n'arrivons pas à percevoir quand l'esprit est dans un état de jalousie.
Parfois, une personne n'aimait pas admettre qu'elle était seule.
Par exemple, certaines personnes n'aiment pas admettre qu'elles se sentent seules.
Donc, parfois, pendant la méditation, quelque chose surgit.
Et nous pouvons en prendre conscience simplement en la notant.
Et donc c'est en la recevant pleinement que cet état mental peut pleinement s'exprimer.
Et comme je l'expliquerai ce soir, cela est votre thérapie.
Parce que nous savons que des états mentaux qui ne sont pas reconnus créent des problèmes pour nous.
une autre erreur que nous faisons parfois c'est de donner une sorte de méthode, une méthodologie, une sorte de mysticisme si nous pouvons obtenir la méthode exactement correcte
Et donc, nous croyons que si nous pouvons avoir la méthode exactement juste, alors nous pourrions être pleinement éveillés, libérés.
Donc, le méditant devient vraiment très concerné sur comment il devrait noter.
Et quand il faudrait noter ?
Est-ce que je le fais correctement ?
Am I noting too loudly, too softly ?
Est-ce que je le fais trop fort ou trop doucement ?
Quand je fais la méditation de marcher, est-ce que mon pied est suffisamment élevé ou trop bas ?
Quand nous sommes obsédés par la technique, nous allons vers la maison mentale.
Donc là, nous nous dirigeons tout droit vers l'hôpital psychiatrique.
Donc ce que nous devons vraiment comprendre, c'est que le seul but d'une technique de vipassana est de maintenir la compréhension du moment par le moment.
c'est de maintenir l'attention, la présence, moment après moment.
Et même si cela n'est pas possible pendant une retraite courte comme celle-là,
Mais la technique vous emmène vers un point où il n'y a plus de technique.
Où il y a juste le fait d'observer, de ressentir et d'expérimenter.
Et cela se passe naturellement avec la croissance de la concentration.
Si vous forcez le processus, alors surgit l'agitation.
Et vous allez vous fatiguer.
Mais si vous ne mettez pas suffisamment d'énergie, alors vous allez finir par vous endormir.
Donc, nous devons être vraiment très clairs sur comment nous employons cette technique.
Je pense que la manière la plus simple de la considérer est la suivante.
Nous voulons
ressentir et expérimenter ce que le corps nous donne Nous pouvons dire que c'est la façon la plus facile d'aborder cette pratique Et qu'est-ce que le corps nous donne ?
Et qu'est-ce que le corps nous donne ?
Le Bouddha n'a qu'un seul mot pour cela, c'est Vedana.
Et Vedana se traduit en anglais comme « sensations, sentiments ».
Vedana est traduit en français par sensation, sentiment.
Et quand nous regardons dans ces expériences, nous pouvons voir que certaines viennent du corps.
Par exemple, la douleur dans les pieds.
Par exemple, la douleur dans le genou.
Et d'autres viennent depuis l'esprit à travers le corps, ou du cœur en direction du corps.
C'est ce que nous appelons les émotions, les états d'esprit.
Et si vous appuyez votre attention sur le ressenti d'une émotion, sur le ressenti d'un mood,
Donc, si vous amenez l'attention sur le ressenti d'une émotion ou d'un état d'âme dans le corps, à ce moment-là, vous calmez.
Donc là, vous clarifiez l'intelligence intuitive.
Donc ces deux mots, sati et panya, sati réfère à l'ouverture ouverte.
C'est cette qualité de recevoir juste.
Donc c'est cette qualité de juste recevoir.
Et à l'intérieur de l'attention, il y a ce potentiel de voir.
Et c'est cela que nous appelons vision profonde.
Même le Bouddha doit utiliser ces deux mots pour décrire la vraie conscience.
Et même le Bouddha a dû utiliser ces deux mots pour décrire l'attention juste.
Dans le discours sur comment établir l'attention juste, il emploie ces trois mots.
Atapi means with effort.
Katapi veut dire avec effort.
Donc l'effort c'est de continuellement établir cette présence, cette attention.
Ce n'est pas l'effort pour obtenir quelque chose.
Sampajano veut dire avec l'intelligence intuitive.
Et Satima veut dire
Donc, nous utilisons cette pratique pour simplement établir une présence ouverte.
Et dans cette présence, il y a le potentiel de voir.
Et à l'intérieur de cette présence, il y a le potentiel de voir.
D'abord nous regardons et ensuite nous voyons.
Donc c'est la même chose par exemple si vous avez une voiture et elle tombe en panne.
Donc, soit vous-même ou le mécanicien va ouvrir le capot.
D'abord, vous regardez.
Et quand vous regardez, vous pouvez voir.
Vous pouvez voir où est le problème.
Donc, si vous regardez en pensant que vous savez pourquoi le véhicule a arrêté, vous ne pouvez pas voir pourquoi le véhicule a arrêté.
Donc si vous regardez avec déjà l'idée de savoir pourquoi la voiture s'est arrêtée, alors il se peut que vous n'alliez pas voir la raison pour laquelle la voiture s'est arrêtée.
Et c'est la même chose à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes.
En développant cette très pure compréhension ouverte, nous permettons à l'intelligence de voir pour elle-même.
Donc, en développant cette attention ouverte, nous permettons à l'intelligence de voir par elle-même.
Et donc, l'autre précaution, c'est de ne pas tourner la note mentale en un mantra.
Et il se peut que vous vous aperceviez que vous preniez l'habitude de la note s'élever, s'abaisser.
Et tout à coup, vous vous mettez à rêver de vos vacances à Acapulco.
Et quand vous revenez, l'esprit est tout content, enfin, note
s'élever, s'abaisser, très content.
Mais ça, ça n'a pas de résultat.
Donc la note doit être délibérée.
OK.
The next thing is to be aware of the... is to
La deuxième chose, c'est de prendre conscience de l'importance de noter l'intention.
Donc, au moment de l'intention, il n'y a pas encore une action.
Donc j'espère pouvoir parler de ça plus en détail demain soir.
Donc une intention c'est une pensée
Juste teinté de vouloir.
Teinté de désir.
Tinté.
Flavoured with desire.
So nothing has happened.
It is when we take that potential into an actual that something happens.
C'est quand nous prenons ce potentiel dans une action que quelque chose se passe.
Malheureusement, nous avons placé les thés et les cafés juste sous votre nez quand vous entrez dans le bâtiment.
Nous faisons déjà une tasse de thé.
Nous devons nous rappeler que nous ne sommes pas ici pour avoir une partie de thé.
Cela peut être de valeur spirituelle de pratiquer la vertu de la renonciation.
Et ça peut être une vertu spirituelle de pratiquer à ce moment-là la renonciation, le renoncement.
Le but de la renonciation dans la pratique du Bouddha est de voir notre attachement.
Donc dans la pratique du Bouddha, le but du renoncement, c'est de voir notre attachement.
Non pas de nous punir.
Nous souffrons déjà assez.
Donc quand nous passons à côté de la table avec le thé et le café,
et nous sentons cet animal surgir dans notre poitrine, nous prendre à la gorge, et nous lancer en direction de la tasse, nous devons rester absolument tranquilles.
Laissez l'animal s'éloigner de notre système,
Laissez l'animal surgir, rugir de notre corps, du système.
Et puis découvrir le contentement d'un esprit sans désir.
Et la dernière chose que j'aimerais aborder, c'est d'aller lentement.
Donc, quand vous regardez un film, un documentaire sur la nature qui est montré au ralenti, à ce moment-là, vous voyez vraiment comment l'animal se meut.
Comment il attrape sa proie.
Par exemple, est-ce que vous savez comment une grenouille attrape une mouche ?
C'est seulement quand j'ai vu un film ralenti mille fois que j'ai pu comprendre ce qui se passait.
La grenouille sort sa langue et attrape la mouche, mais par dessous la langue.
Et elle se colle à la salive.
Et puis ensuite, elle la ramène jusqu'à l'intérieur de l'estomac.
Donc c'est pareil avec nous.
Donc c'est la même chose avec nous.
Le plus lentement nous allons et le plus nous verrons.
Et nous pourrons voir comment un désir surgit dans l'esprit.
Et nous pourrons voir le pouvoir du désir de satisfaire l'intention
Vous verrez... Oh, j'ai oublié moi-même maintenant.
Voilà, merci.
Et en l'observant, vous verrez aussi comment cela disparaît.
Juste de cette façon, vous devenez très clair sur comment changer votre caractère et votre personnalité.
Juste de cette manière, vous pourrez changer votre personnalité et votre caractère.
Et aussi de savoir comment gérer des états mentaux difficiles.
Juste de cette manière, en pénétrant très clairement chaque instant,
vous verrez que chaque instant apparaît et disparaît complètement.
C'est seulement l'esprit qui nous donne cette impression de continuité.
Just like a film, the old film, we know it's made up of little photographs.
C'est comme les vieux films qui sont faits avec des petites photos.
Mais quand nous voyons un film, nous ne le voyons pas.
Donc, c'est la magie de l'esprit.
Mais ça crée aussi pour nous l'illusion.
Et l'illusion ne serait pas si mauvaise si elle ne créait pas de souffrance.
l'illusion ne serait pas si mauvaise si elle ne créait pas la souffrance si nous étions toujours heureux dans l'illusion quel serait le problème ?
Donc laissez-moi vous encourager vraiment d'aller très lentement autant que possible.
Donc soyez attentif quand par exemple vous faites la queue pour le repas.
Parfois vous devez aller à une vitesse normale.
La frustration et l'irritation de la personne derrière vous
Il peut s'exprimer avec une fourchette dans votre dos.
Donc, soyez attentif à toutes les situations.
Mais, où que vous puissiez, allez vraiment lentement et faites tout très délicatement.
Ah oui.
Et pendant le Kama Yoga, c'est important d'aller à une vitesse normale.
Tout d'abord, on ne se nourrit pas.
Si vous ne le faites pas, vous ne serez pas nourris.
C'est aussi important pour nous de transférer notre pratique de la méditation dans notre pratique de notre vie de tous les jours.
Et de comprendre que cela est une certaine pratique pour atteindre une certaine compréhension, réalisation, vision profonde.
Mais apparemment, bien sûr, nous ne pouvons pas nous comporter comme ça dans la vie de tous les jours.
Il y aurait un certain danger de traverser la route comme ça, le vent, déplacer, poser.
Donc le Karma Yoga est une occasion de voir que nous pouvons développer la présence, l'attention également dans la vie de tous les jours.
Donc c'est juste une attention ordinaire, instant après instant.
Dans la tradition mahasis, la vision profonde est justement comprise quand nous ne sommes pas dans l'assise.
Parce que dans l'assise, quelque part, nous espérons avoir des résultats.
Donc, trois choses.
Le processus de noter est pour fermer l'esprit pensant.
Et il doit être fait délibérément et continuellement.
cela doit être fait délibérément et continuellement sur la continuité et voyez si vous pouvez noter vos intentions autant que possible même quand vous vous levez de la position assise notez avoir l'intention de se lever et allez lentement
Et puis, allez lentement.
Détendez-vous.
Donc, le mot principal pour aujourd'hui, c'est relax, détente.